hallo herzlich willkommen bei sallyies 5
Minuten heute gibt's ein richtig
schnelles Rezept für
euch und zwar haben wir uns gedacht
machen wir heute was mit Schupfnudeln
Schupfnudeln im manzu Style das heißt
die türkischen Teigtaschen die wir alle
so sehr lieben die man selbst machen
kann aber auch beim türkischen
Supermarkt kaufen kann mit einer
leckeren Joghurtsoße gibt's heute als
Schupfnudeln denn ich muss sagen wir
essen ganz gerne Schupfnudeln ich mache
sie auch mal selber aber ich muss auch
sagen wir haben immer fertige
Schupfnudeln auch im Kühlschrank wenn es
mal schnell gehen muss und wir einfach
mittags Hunger haben ich zeige euch mal
kurz die Zutaten dafür verwende ich 500
g Hackfleisch etwas Olivenöl eine
Zwiebel und knoblauchzeh die habe ich
bereits zerkleinert einen Esslöffel
Paprikamark zwei Esslöffel Tomatenmark
etwas Wasser Salz und Pfeffer und
natürlich Schupfnudeln da habe ich jetzt
1 Kil wird erstmal etwas Olivenöl in der
Pfanne erhitzt und dann das Hackfleisch
darin krümelig
[Musik]
gebraten und wenn es hier schön krümelig
ist dann kommen die Zwiebel und
Knoblauchwürfel dazu und wenn hier am
Boden des gusseisentopfes irgendwas
angebrannt ist ist gar nicht schlimm das
angebrannt sind einfach Röstaromen und
die lösen sich gleich sobald ich Wasser
dazu geb also ich lass es schon immer
schön scharf anbraten damit sich eben
Röstaromen auch
[Musik]
bilden jetzt ziehe ich das einfach kurz
auf die Seite und brate hier die
schubfnudeln
[Musik]
an
und jetzt kommen
hier Paprika und Tomatenmark dazu Wasser
Salz und Pfeffer und wird eigentlich nur
noch ein bisschen
geköchelt die schufnudelpfanne WT sich
jetzt noch mit Salz und Pfeffer dann ist
schubknudelpfanne fertig und dann wird
das Ganze serviert mit einem Joghurt ihr
könnt Joghurt oder skir nehmen mit Salz
und Pfeffer mischen und etwas Knoblauch
dazu reiben und mit Minze abschmecken in
einer zweiten Pfanne könnt ihr dann
gerne etwas Butter schmelzen
Paprikapulver dazu geben entweder süß
oder scharf ich habe immer das edelsüße
Paprikapulver wird kurz mit angebraten
und das war's auch schon und jetzt wird
es hier schön
platziert
[Applaus]
und dann einfach nur noch alles
vermischen und Essen
lecker
ich geb da jetzt noch Chiliöl drauf und
dann wird gegessen und ihr könt das
Rezept nachlesen in meiner App oder auch
auf meinem Blog auf sellies-blog.de
wünsche euch viel Spaß dabei schreibt
mir auch gerne mal wie ihr Schupfnudeln
am liebsten esst meine Kids z.B Essen es
ganz gerne mit etwas Apfelmus ich lieb
es auch mit Sauerkraut ich liebe aber
auch schubfnudel mit Gurke und Schmand
und
Dill schubfnudel Z variationsreich also
bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss
[Musik]